ariana grande traded in her heels and
her high pony for cowboy hat and boots
in a new audition reel to prove to blake
shelton that she's country enough to be
in his music video for come back as a
country boy take a look and we'll see
you back here tomorrow
howdy howdy
hi i'm ariana grande and this is my
audition tape for blake shelton's music
video come back as a country boy i'm 5'2
i'm with caa and yeah here i am
oh
blake doesn't think i'm country enough
but i told him he's so wrong so
hopefully this will really show him what
he needs to see
catch the beer cans
[Music]
we can also cut to me with it
[Music]
ariana chainsaw marker
are you sure it's charged i think this
one is defective
thank you
i'll get mine i can always get mine
i can run and get it
ariana porch scene marker
i'm gonna sit like blake wood
and then you're just gonna do you
no no i need you to please
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry ariana's
singing marker
when i die
i hope i come back as
a country boy
yeehaw
[Applause]
did i get it we'll let you know okay